all right we could all use some
inspiration and insight when it comes to
survival of illness
and business local businessman ron corey
is back to share his personal story
from his new book check it out ron
welcome back to the show
hi rocky thank you for having me back
great to see you again we're talking
tenacity your book
that you wrote about your incredible
life story
and achieving the american dream and
surviving so much
so i want to start with um something
really relevant to the times
you survived cancer but also survived
covet
too so let's talk about that journey and
let's start with cancer first
at the age of 53 i was diagnosed with an
esophageal tumor
the surgery only has an 8 survival rate
and you need to have strength
in body and mind to overcome something
like that
just think about the two weeks between
being diagnosed
and reporting for surgery the gains that
plays on your mind that
you may not survive it 92 out of 100
people don't
so what happened in my case was my
doctor in santa barbara jim murray
found the tumor at a very young stage
and i want people who may be struggling
with their own or a family member
with the medical challenge to understand
staying in good shape
early detection are keys to surviving
major illness
specifically cancer and of course
covid as we as we're in a pandemic um
you survived that too let's talk about
your experience with that and any advice
you
have for families going through it so my
lungs were already damaged so when i
developed a colder diagnosis in july
my doctors were very concerned about
what it might do if it went to my lungs
i had no
sense of taste and i was extremely
fatigued
but i got very lucky with early
detection and proper treatment just like
with the cancer
to be covered after two weeks and to be
here today talking to
you from survival of illness to survival
in the business world and specifically
the business world of las vegas
right the title of the book was
specifically chosen because
it took some tenacity to overcome some
of the challenges in business
that i faced and demonstrating
perseverance
perseverance diligence
and some level of tenacity is how to
overcome
the hurdles that will surely come your
way one day
now let's talk about how people can get
your book and
and what they should expect sure
they can find my book either through my
website
which has a quick click through to
amazon
the website is ron cory author dot com
or go right to amazon and enter tenacity
by ron corey and they can order the book
in paperback hardcover kindle
or the audio version where i hired
well-known actor michael madsen from
donnie brasco and reservoir dogs to do
my audiobook
you can get your copy of tenacity on
amazon and for more information like you
just said
head to roncoryauthor.com lindsay i'll
send it to you